alain bashung bonsoir alors on a reçu
ici à quelques semaines ton complice son
parolier halte et parolier boris bergman
qui nous a appris bien triste nouvelle
puisqu'il nous a dit que maintenant
après novice était signé quoi je me suis
rendu compte d'un truc c'est que
plus on se fréquentait comme ça plus on
parlait et moi on écrivait des chansons
qu'il avait l'air de dire aussi que tu
étais devenu quand même très con
couleurs très quoi kooner c'est à dire
que tu étais avec chantal arthur les
quatre chats dans la maison oui vous
aviez le même style de vie si j'avais la
preuve que sortir jusqu'à 9h du mat tous
les jours en face de belles chansons je
crois on continuera à le faire
ouais elle est une époque oblige à les
traîner tous les matins de jaser parce
que c'était complètement tordue il y
avait des vieux films il ya des salles
dégueulis dans les chiottes
il se passait quelque chose de touchant
tu vois là rien c'est clean comment t'y
vas tu
comme les tubes you and i bon alors
c'est un peu le bilan de nos vies cela
sur la critique c'est parfait comme ça
ressemblait plus à appeler blessure qu'à
rio grande et la critique a été
dithyrambique les ventes ça s'est passé
comment on va on va dépasser son rang
dans leur sous la faillite en temps ça
va
finalement même si c'était voulu
au fond de toi et avec le recul est ce
que la redescente après gaby après
verte' ça a été douloureux convient
maintenant je peux le dire
moi ce que je voyais c'est que
effectivement rien et ses deux tubes qui
à un moment donné on
pour montrer que je pouvais que cette
musique pouvait être rentable mais mon
but c'était arrivé à faire des albums
qui eux ce band s'est pas seulement
avoir une espèce de tubes et ensuite tu
fais un truc sur celle qui est vraiment
toi et tu passes ton temps à expliquer
je fais j'ai fait un tube mais vous
savez je fais d'autres trucs
bon ça st je n'avais pas envie d'être à
côté de mes pompes et je crois que le
les gens s'intéressent aux albums et
près la vente à l'interview première
fois j'essaie de me souvenir premier
boulot je dorme j'étais un peu la
boulangerie ouais j'ai d un peu la
boulangerie je livrais des trucs jeu
libre et des pièces montées pour pour
les communions pour les mariages ça va
me donner une pièce c'était avant la
contraste ouais ouais premier fleurs
elle s'appelait marie jeunes avant
j'habitais dans une maison du village
qui était tendance catholique elle
habitait dans un nouveau village d'un
kilomètre de chez elle c'était plutôt
protestons et il y avait un problème
dans la za land art qu'on se rend compte
mais à mi-chemin sam alsace ouais
c'était l'enfer t'avais pas le droit de
jouer avec les petits délits d'en face
comme tu dis dans la chanson s'était
coincée ou s il y avait les juifs les
protestants les cathos ça c'est du vrai
de vrai puis il y avait des vieilles il
y avait des vues des vieux bus de
règlements de compte qui datait de la
guerre et intel qui avait dénoncé l'
intérêt et une telle qu'ils avaient
couché à paris notamment la france mal à
prendre est la première fille avec qui
tu as fais l'amour quand souvient ouest
une brune ouais c'était pas terrible
c'était la sortie d'un cinéma on s'est
retrouvé dans dans un hangar entre entre
une moissonneuse batteuse
et parce que tu es dans un hangar
machines agricoles et
je suis très vite fait hier 17 c'était
déjà mieux premier gars ont commencé un
premier gars avaient quitté fait l'amour
robert je suis encore vierge de ce côté
là oui oui oui je ne sais pas j'ai un
jour je me suis retrouvé dans un pieu
avec un mec comme ça il vendait comme un
fouet et met une touche est à peine
comme ça et moi je voulais dormir vend
plus j'étais étonné par semaine parce
que je le faisais bande et je trouvais
ça fascinant et a pas essayé
non maintenant les gars est dangereux
c'est gratuit l'époque ça me paraissait
dangereux aussi mais l'on flatte
essayera puis première put se 19 ans
sert pierre charon ce que je chantais
dans un dvd put rue pierre charron
baillet d'un club qui s'appelait le club
pierre charon j'avais été engagée je
devais avoir dix neuf ans comme ça et je
chantais cinq ou six chansons tous les
soirs avec une guitare sèche emporte
harmonica
chanter des chansons de dylan mary
mcdowell comme ça yves destruction qui
les destructions à grands moments
extrêmes beaucoup et il y avait des
filles barre et puis j'étais devenu
copain avec 15 ont passé des nuits
ensemble des fois jumaa tram payés
d'espagne où c'était super
le protégé carrément qui va j'aurais pu
mal tourner mais je ne voyais pas comme
une idée enfin j'ai quand on me parle de
suite je suis un peu choqué par le monde
parce que j'ai vu des filles super un
premier succès c'était beaucoup plus
tard c'était quoi le premier succès de
gastines jusqu'à gagner rien c'était
carrément ouais on peut pas appeler ça
il y avait du bricolage partout c'est
entre le moment où tu as décidé de
devenir artiste et le moment où tafer
gaby il s'est passé combien de temps
dix ans dix ans dix ans puis accrue pas
forcément mais je rencontre toujours un
conte qui me disait écoute c'est bien ce
que tu fais
le
c'est bizarre a expliqué genre de truc
pourquoi tu insistes ou
c'est pas normal ce serait beau l'armée
ya peut-être certainement le fait que
j'ai essayé de bosser je sais faire
détruire
j'essayais de mais je sentais tellement
que il y avait ma vie pouvait pas être
vraiment fait avec et une envie de
gagner de l'argent comme ça je préférais
mourir voyais pas ça comme ça est
devenue la compta chez péchiney se
comprend besoin j'ai vu tout de suite
que tu répètes mans s'il avait été
comptable il ya un truc que ça marche
pas si les musiques de films a fait
plein de gigle hâtives et fait cinq-six
soins et la convaincre 60 pas pas une je
sois way d'affaires a cédé un jour avec
les musiques de films de passion mais je
m'attends j'aimerais j'aimerais bien
c'est sur un 24 quelque sorte que l'on
dit que si un jour les voir collector
haythem un jour premier million de
nouveaux fronts oui quand pas ce devait
être les cabines ouais ouais tu est à la
peine les ai pas vus en fait vous ai pas
vu beaucoup il ya tout de suite eu des
impôts j'étais en train de divorcer
c'était un ramdam
incroyable c'est ça qui est fantastique
quand ça marche parce que tu vois très
grosse île et les choses fantastiques et
tu vois grossi aussi la connerie là et
la jalousie et tout ces trucs en plus
énormes aussi non bon premier procès mon
bourse
ouais si on peut appeler ça un procès
s'arranger quand même elle demandait
beaucoup elle a eu très peur elle
demandait trop alors à y faire attention
en en tout
c'est louche et à dernières volontés tu
devais mourir
ce serait quoi bon jeu prendre un bain
présentable à